Hey guys, it's the Tapestry Theory of E-Collective podcast, Discover, Kill, Grow. And today we're talking about the psychology of the katana, the Japanese samurai sword. So I'm here with James Waits and with Alice Hawley. Hi, there. And we're going to go through the psychology of swords. James has some personal stories and also advanced techniques he's going to go through the psychology of swords. James has some personal stories and also advanced techniques he's going to share with us from his training. And Alice is going to go through some of the spirituality and the esoteric connections that swords share
大家好，这里是E-Collective播客的“挂毯理论”，我是Discover, Kill, Grow。今天我们要讨论的是武士刀的心理学，也就是日本武士剑。今天和我在一起的有詹姆斯·韦茨（James Waits）和爱丽丝·霍利（Alice Hawley）。你们好。我们将探讨剑的心理学。詹姆斯有一些个人故事，还有他从训练中总结出的进阶技巧要与我们分享。爱丽丝则会探讨剑在不同文化中所共有的灵性与深奥联系。
across culture. So I'm going to just to jump into this quickly because we got a little bit of time today. I am a metallurgy nerd. Like my wife would tell you that I like knives, but I'm not like really into knives as much as like super purpose driven steels. I think you're just kind of interesting that you can have something that is like as ubiquitous as metal, but it is as different as you can make steel. So I don't like I have a couple of knives. I'm not really, I don't really collect that. I'm more interested in like different things. And so a katana is a little bit different than a Western sword. There's a lot of sort of amateur and professional
所以，因为今天时间有限，我就直接切入正题了。我是一个冶金迷。我妻子会告诉你我喜欢刀，但我对刀的痴迷程度不如对那些功能导向型钢材的痴迷。我觉得很有趣的一点是，你可以拥有像金属这样普遍的东西，但它又能被制成各种截然不同的钢材。我并不是那种收藏家，我只是对不同的事物更感兴趣。武士刀与西方剑有所不同。在这个领域里，有很多业余和专业的
like pseudoscience out there in that space, like about what katanas can do and whether or not they're magic. But so like, if you look at something like this, then my webcam is not great. But you can kind of see the layers on the metal here and like the maker's mark on the side. And my webcam is trying to make it disappear.
伪科学，比如关于武士刀能做什么，以及它们是否具有魔力。所以，如果你看这样的东西——我的网络摄像头不太好——但你可以在这里看到金属上的纹理，还有侧面的刀匠印记。我的摄像头正试图让它消失。
So this thing was covered in rust when we stayed at this like really cheap kind of tacky bed and breakfast in like Tennessee. And they had all these like dollar general knives in the drawer. But there is one where I kept telling my wife, I think this one's actually like a VG-10 or like white paper one or something.
当我们住在田纳西州一家非常便宜、俗气的民宿时，这把刀上全是锈。抽屉里放着各种“一元店”级别的刀。但其中有一把，我一直跟我妻子说，我觉得这把其实是VG-10钢或者白纸钢之类的。
I think this is a high carbon steel. Because a lot of the steels that Japan uses, they're forged. And they're folded to kind of laminate the blade with different metals. We'll get into what that looks like with a katana, but they have a different they have like a different texture. Like you can almost kind of feel. I don't know if it's the crystal structure or what it is, but there's like a slickness
我觉得这是高碳钢。因为日本使用的很多钢材都是锻造的。它们经过折叠，将不同金属层压在刀刃上。我们稍后会详细讨论武士刀的样子，但它们有一种不同的质感。你几乎可以感觉到，我不知道是晶体结构还是什么，但有一种光滑感，
that's almost like fish scales to some of them. And this thing was covered in rust. Like I have it completely like sanded down now. But I asked the guy, I was like, I think this is like a really expensive knife. Like I don't want to. But it seems to be like going to waste here. Would you take like thirty dollars for it? I think this is like a really expensive knife. Like I don't want to. But it seems to be like going to waste here. Would you take like thirty dollars for it? I think this is like a three or four hundred dollar thing.
对其中一些刀来说，就像鱼鳞一样。这把刀当时满是锈迹。我现在已经把它完全打磨干净了。但我问那个人，我说，我觉得这是一把非常昂贵的刀，我不想……但它在这里似乎被浪费了。你愿意三十美元卖给我吗？我觉得这是一把非常昂贵的刀，我不想……但它在这里似乎被浪费了。你愿意三十美元卖给我吗？我觉得这东西值三四百美元。
But I don't know. I could be wrong. And like he just said, four hundred dollars is too much to have for a knife. And then he like took the thirty dollars and gave it to me. So I cleaned it up when I came home and ends up that it is like, you know, about a three hundred and fifty dollar Japanese like knife that's folded. So like the thing that makes the steel different, like this is probably like you know, about a $350 Japanese like knife that's folded. So like the thing that makes the steel different, like this is probably like a steel like VG 10 or white paper one.
但我不知道，我也可能错了。他只是说，四百美元买把刀太贵了。然后他收了三十美元，把它给了我。所以我回家后把它清理干净，结果发现它确实是一把价值约三百五十美元的折叠日本刀。所以，让钢材与众不同的东西，这可能就是VG-10或白纸钢之类的。
Like when you deal with like Western steel, like from the medieval period, a lot of it is designed to be like durable and floppy. It's something that would be like similar to like what a modern spring steel is. Whereas, and it's not like wivvily floppy, but you don't want to hit a suit of armor and then have your sword bend. Whereas with the East, they had something called Damascus steel or Wootz steel, which
当你处理中世纪的西方钢材时，很多设计是为了耐用和柔韧。它类似于现代的弹簧钢。当然，它不是那种软塌塌的，但你肯定不希望在击中盔甲后剑就弯了。而在东方，他们有大马士革钢或乌兹钢，
you start seeing in the history, Western history when people are encountering it. And essentially, they would throw just a lot lot of grass and straw like into the Arabs would until like you started to get a ton of carbonization. And that carbonization is something that you can make the steel a whole lot harder. So when you make it hard, it's more likely to break because it is a lot more rigid, but it also can hold like a much finer edge. Like it can it can hold and so if you're dealing with a long like
你在历史中开始看到，当西方人接触到它时。本质上，他们会把大量的草和秸秆扔进炉子里，直到产生大量的碳化。这种碳化可以使钢材变得坚硬得多。所以当你把它做硬时，它更容易折断，因为它更刚硬，但它也能保持更锋利的刃口。所以如果你面对的是一把长长的
Arabic sword that you're gonna swing from horseback or something that's pretty useful. Whereas if you're gonna fight a suit of armor it may not be as useful. And so that's wuts or Damascus steel. So the way that it's pretty amazing like what Japanese Smiths, because in Japan, there's like some overlap with the rest of the world. But now like we basically know about the crystal structure of metals, that there's like crystals inside of these things that you were making, and that that you can model that in 3d, you can figure out like what you can do to martensite to like add another atom to it. But obviously, they don't have anything like that. So you have people that are basically just sort of like banging hot metal and folding it until they
阿拉伯剑，你要在马背上挥舞，那是非常有用的。但如果你要对抗盔甲，它可能就没那么好用了。这就是乌兹钢或大马士革钢。日本刀匠的做法非常令人惊叹，因为在日本，这与世界其他地方有一些重叠。但现在我们基本上了解了金属的晶体结构，知道这些东西内部有晶体，你可以对其进行三维建模，算出如何对马氏体进行处理以增加一个原子。但显然，他们当时没有这些。所以这些人基本上只是在敲打热金属并折叠它，直到他们
like discover incredibly complex things, which is kind of interesting. And so the the history, the quick history of the Japanese katana is that, you know, you've got these swords that are relatively soft, they start to take on like a little bit of a curve, but when they're Mongol invasions of Japan are happening, the king is like, the emperor is like, these things don't, and this is probably an oversimplified history, we don't have a good enough weapon, what do we do?
发现了极其复杂的东西，这很有趣。日本武士刀的简史是，你知道，这些剑相对较软，开始带有一点弧度，但当蒙古入侵日本时，天皇说，这些东西……这可能是一个过于简化的历史，我们没有足够好的武器，我们该怎么办？
And that one of the master forgers invents the Katana and figures out his name's Masamune. It probably is like a lot of different techniques that come together over time, but the pop history is that one guy just invents it in his shed and takes it to the Emperor, which maybe that happens, and he says, you know, that if you put clay along the side of the sword, you're going to get a harder edge because you're cooling it at different temperatures and the sword's also gonna bend. So the bend comes from the actual crystal structure
其中一位锻造大师发明了武士刀，并弄清楚了——他的名字叫正宗（Masamune）。这可能是在很长一段时间内多种技术的结合，但流行历史认为是一个人在棚子里发明了它并把它带给了天皇，也许确实如此。他说，如果你在剑的侧面涂上粘土，你会得到一个更硬的刃口，因为你在不同的温度下冷却它，而且剑也会弯曲。所以弯曲来自于实际的晶体结构
diverging and pulling against itself, not because they just bent a metal rod and a katana. And then also he figures out a way to layer steels and fold them together so that you get the properties of both. So you can get a really rigid edge that if you made the whole sword out of that, it would shatter like glass. But when you're folding it in kind of a Z shape along the spine with softer metals,
发散并相互拉扯，而不是因为他们只是把金属棒弯成了武士刀。他还想出了一种分层折叠钢材的方法，这样你就能同时获得两者的特性。所以你可以得到一个非常坚硬的刃口，如果整把剑都用这种材料做，它会像玻璃一样破碎。但当你沿着脊部以Z字形折叠它，并加入较软的金属时，
it's going to benefit from the flexibility of those. And so these are front weighted swords like they're not like balanced like a western sword that you could really spin or something, because you're supposed to be playing. And James will probably go into more of that like with the momentum of these things they're weighted six about six inches from the hills or the suba so like a lot of these these things have more to do with the way that you play with the inertia of it than just something that's when you hear of a masterwork sword, you probably think it's like super wieldy,
它就会受益于那些金属的柔韧性。所以这些是前重式剑，它们不像西方剑那样平衡，你可以随意旋转。因为你是要进行格斗的。詹姆斯可能会深入探讨这一点，比如它们的动量，它们的重心距离护手（Tsuba）大约六英寸。所以这些东西更多地与你如何利用惯性有关，而不是当你听到名剑时，你可能认为它非常顺手、
super well balanced. And when you first hold a katana, like they're kind of unwieldy. Like you're like, for example, like in Budo or Eido or Kendo, one of the drawing forms, like, you know, you could be the strongest guy in the world, but that doesn't, and you could hit really hard,
非常平衡。当你第一次握住武士刀时，它们有点笨重。比如，在武道、居合道或剑道中，其中一种拔刀术，你知道，你可能是世界上最强壮的人，但这并不意味着，你可能击打得非常有力，
but that doesn't mean that you can necessarily accelerate something faster. Muscles tend to have like a set speed that enzymes can accelerate them But when you're drawing the sword you push it against the scabbard and kind of a triangle shape away from you And you you keep about two inches of the blade inside of the scabbard or the seya So when you're pushing it out you're getting this tension built up So that when you pull the scabbard off or the seahawf, that blade is going to pop out with a ton of force. So it's like little
但这并不意味着你能让某样东西加速得更快。肌肉往往有一个酶可以加速的固定速度。但当你拔剑时，你把它推向鞘口，形成一个远离你的三角形。你让刀刃在鞘内保持大约两英寸。所以当你把它推出来时，你积聚了张力，这样当你把鞘拔掉时，那把刀就会带着巨大的力量弹出来。所以就像这样的小
tensioning tricks like that are kind of what make this a different style and a different psychology of fighting than the West. So that got a little bit more on some of the blacksmiths and the history there, but I'm going to turn that over to James to kind of go from there because he's got some stories will break up the flow a little bit. Yeah. Well, I was going to say I'm a I'm a freaking nerd when it comes to all this and really just the history part. You're right, after the Mongol invasion, Masamune actually studied broken blades and was trying to figure out why are we breaking our blades against these invaders they had a lot of shields So you can imagine
张力技巧，使它成为一种与西方不同的风格和战斗心理。关于铁匠和历史的内容就说到这里，我要把话语权交给詹姆斯，让他继续讲，因为他有一些故事可以调节一下节奏。是的，我想说，当谈到这一切时，我简直是个书呆子，尤其是历史部分。你是对的，蒙古入侵后，正宗实际上研究了断裂的刀刃，并试图弄清楚为什么我们的刀刃在对抗这些入侵者时会断裂，他们有很多盾牌。所以你可以想象
At the time that Japan was on my majority horseback shooting bows and had long kind of like naginata as which are you know staff swords big staff long blade and They they it's like a sword bladed spear in it. Yeah. Naginata. Yeah. So it's just a, a thicker blade all the way through and some, some fitted that blade to actual sword hilts and use that on foot. But yeah, that was the primary, that was a part primary fighting way of the samurai,
当时日本大部分是骑马射箭，并有长柄薙刀（Naginata），也就是长柄刀。它们就像是带刃的长矛。是的，薙刀。所以它是一把贯穿始终的厚刀刃，有些人把那刀刃装在真正的剑柄上，在步战中使用。但是的，那是武士的主要战斗方式，
especially when, when the Mongols invaded and they hit Tsushima and Iki Island. You know, they got shocked. The Mongols, they had bombs. So this is the first time that we saw, kind of like in Japan, saw iron bombs being thrown. They also fought people with shields and with like this crazy type of armor, heavier armor. And noticing that their arrows are bouncing off. Arrows are kind of bouncing off. The only way that they were able to kind of win some of the battles on those islands were the close quarter combat of just the rage of the samurai or not the rage of the warriors back then they even got wrote about was that a Japanese person with a sword is a scary thing after the
特别是在蒙古人入侵并袭击对马岛和壹岐岛时。你知道，他们被震惊了。蒙古人有炸弹。所以这是我们在日本第一次看到铁制炸弹被投掷。他们还与使用盾牌和那种疯狂盔甲的人作战，更重的盔甲。并注意到他们的箭被弹开了。箭被弹开了。他们在那些岛屿上获胜的唯一方式是近距离格斗，仅仅是武士的愤怒，或者说当时战士的愤怒。甚至有记载说，日本人在第一次入侵后，拿着剑是非常可怕的，
first invasion and that was written about them before they I think they arrived back at like 1281 again we had a typhoon help out with you know the sinking of the Mongol ships before they landed on mainland Japan. But that was a crazy thing, too. There was a lot of spirituality in that time. The Shogun and the head of, I guess, well, kind of the military-esque, not really big Shogun at that moment.
那是在他们1281年再次到达之前写的。我们有台风帮忙，在他们登陆日本本土之前沉没了蒙古船只。但那也是一件疯狂的事情。那个时代有很多灵性。幕府将军和军事首领，当时还没有真正的大幕府。
But that was the spread of Buddhism through that. And it was the way the warrior way Bushido after that. That was what Toki, Toki Mune. At the time, there was no solid thing, Japan, like solid religion or solid type of thinking way. We didn't see the samurai show up until after this moment in general. So a lot of the thinking from Buddhism and Zen and Shintoism were kind of the thing that creates the like the Bushido, like the kind of the warrior way at that time.
但那是佛教传播的时期。在那之后是武士道。那是时宗（Tokimune）时期。当时没有固定的东西，日本没有稳固的宗教或稳固的思维方式。直到那一刻之后，我们才真正看到武士的出现。所以很多来自佛教、禅宗和神道教的思想，在当时创造了武士道，即战士之道。
So it was kind of broken up. You know, we get a lot of at the Mongol invasion, there's no really kind of like set and stone warrior delivery system until after, in fact, after they redid all these things, created the katana. Masamune found a better sword. He created one. And you had the shogun at the time kind of transcend religion throughout the ranks. So he spread basically Buddhism or Zen through the warrior class. And so you have these kind of elite soldiers that come up from that. So you have the ones that are studying poetry, that are kind of meditating and finding their inner self, the warrior self, you
所以它有点支离破碎。你知道，在蒙古入侵时，并没有真正固定的战士交付系统，直到后来，事实上，在他们重做所有这些事情并创造了武士刀之后。正宗找到了一把更好的剑。他创造了一把。当时的幕府将军在各阶层中超越了宗教。所以他基本上在武士阶层中传播了佛教或禅宗。所以你有了从那里面崛起的精英士兵。所以你有那些研究诗歌、冥想并寻找内在自我、战士自我的人，你
know, that the kind of the Bushido, their warrior way, a sense of like, kind of some kind of essence of stoicism, except that you have you have them express in a lot of ways. You see a lot of samurai expressed through art, whether it's poetry, writing, even art would block all those things. So you have a really change in Japanese society in that moment, which is the one of the craziest things about that time. Well, and one of the things when we talk about like the psychology of the katana that you're hitting on that I'd like to hear you kind of talk to specifically, if you have a second is like, there are these sort of interesting tensions in Japanese culture, because I think we view it as like, that it likes tradition or
知道，那种武士道，他们的战士之道，一种斯多葛主义的本质，除了你有多种表达方式。你看到很多武士通过艺术表达，无论是诗歌、写作，甚至是木版画。所以那一刻日本社会发生了巨大的变化，这是那个时代最疯狂的事情之一。嗯，当我们谈论武士刀的心理学时，你提到的这一点，如果还有时间，我想听你具体谈谈，日本文化中存在着这种有趣的张力，因为我认为我们将其视为喜欢传统、
that it likes authority or that it likes like personal work and reflection in ways where when you really sit with the culture, there's kind of like an equilibrium to it. Like, you know, Japan has an emperor, but the emperor and you have to show fealty to the emperor and you have to show all this respect and they're proud of the emperor, but the emperor really isn't that powerful. Like the shoguns actually ran the country, which continues until World War Two, where there's still debate about whether or not the emperor was even really that important or if it was the generals that were going to run the country, which they probably were. And so that idea of being both an artist and a warrior, that you had to be both,
或喜欢权威、或喜欢个人修行和反思，但当你真正深入了解这种文化时，它有一种平衡感。比如，日本有天皇，你必须对天皇表现出忠诚，表现出所有的尊重，他们为天皇感到骄傲，但天皇实际上并没有那么大的权力。幕府将军实际上统治着国家，这种情况一直持续到二战，当时关于天皇是否真的那么重要，还是由将军们统治国家，仍然存在争论，而他们很可能确实是这样。所以那种既是艺术家又是战士的想法，你必须两者兼备，
or that somehow your art was informing the warrior culture, so many of these things were a response to limitations. The thing about the Mongol invasion that made the swords and the warfare have to change is that Japan is a pretty metal poor country. Like there's not a ton of metal resources, especially not accessible at the time. So when the Mongols came in, they basically had hardened leather armor that was just, it was boiled, it was probably chemically treated, it was woven differently, and it was like hard to cut through. And they also had iron plate, which there just wasn't enough iron for there to even be like what you would have seen in the bronze age in some places of Europe. In Japan, you know,
或者说你的艺术在某种程度上塑造了战士文化，这些很多是对局限性的回应。关于蒙古入侵使得剑和战争必须改变的一点是，日本是一个相当缺乏金属的国家。金属资源不多，尤其是当时无法获取的资源。所以当蒙古人进来时，他们基本上有硬化皮革盔甲，它是煮过的，可能经过化学处理，编织方式不同，很难切开。他们还有铁板，那里甚至没有足够的铁来制造你在欧洲某些地方青铜时代看到的东西。在日本，你知道，
almost closer to the Renaissance, there just wasn't enough for there to be like infantry iron armor. And that's what was breaking the swords was that, you know, they had, they didn't have the resources of these other countries, but what they did was they had this culture that was able to contemplate itself, you know, go inward and then come up with these creations. And then the culture is like still very proud of that. So, you know, when you could you talk about like in Bushido, the way of like, you know, some of that's Taoism, too, I think, that idea that that you have energy is really what's behind everything. So that same energy that is cultivated in art
几乎接近文艺复兴时期，根本没有足够的铁来制造步兵铁甲。这就是导致剑断裂的原因，你知道，他们没有其他国家的资源，但他们拥有这种能够自我反思的文化，你知道，向内探索，然后想出这些创造。而且这种文化仍然为此感到非常自豪。所以，你能谈谈武士道吗？那种方式，我认为其中一些也是道教，那种认为能量是背后一切的想法。所以那种在艺术中培养的能量
can also be cultivated in war. The energy that is held still in the body in meditation is also preparing to come outward through combat, things like that. I don't know. Because it seems like that's kind of what you're hitting on. I'd like to, you have more kind of practical experience with that than I do.
也可以在战争中培养。在冥想中保持静止的身体能量也准备通过战斗向外释放，诸如此类。我不知道。因为这似乎就是你所触及的。我想，你在这方面比我有更多的实践经验。
Yeah, no, you kind of learned, it's been forever since I you know, I did kindo and shinned kindo a good bit God about ten years ago And you got you learn a lot about the cuts or the kata that they get go through and they all are in some specific way tied to yourself and tied to your enemy. And it's really about the confidence in you. Your confidence, your kind of like your solid state is gonna be the thing that overcomes enemy.
是的，不，你学到了，距离我做剑道和新剑道已经过去很久了，大约十年前。你学到了很多关于切法或型（Kata）的知识，它们都以某种特定的方式与你自己和你的敌人联系在一起。这真的关乎你的自信。你的自信，你的那种稳固状态将是战胜敌人的东西。
If you for a second think about, and we'll get to that when we talk about Musashi, but the thought of, could I lose this? You've already lost type thinking. It's really about, you have to, you and yourself have to be confident in your sword. Your sword is extension of you and if you don't have no confidence down the line, you've already lost and that's the thing with Shinkendo, the biggest thing in that that's a that's a type of martial art that is not necessarily like
如果你有一秒钟想到，我们谈到武藏时会谈到这一点，但那种想法，我可能会输吗？你已经输了。这真的关乎，你必须，你和你自己必须对你的剑有信心。你的剑是你自己的延伸，如果你没有信心，你已经输了，这就是新剑道（Shinkendo）的东西，这是武术中最大的东西，它不一定像
like full like full- on kendo, meaning that it's not, you're not dueling the entire time. Shinkendo is more about your footwork, about the actual martial art of stances, things like that. But the biggest thing what happens at the end of Shinkendo when you get up in rank, you do Toshimagiri, so test cutting. So you actually, you go up through the ranks where you actually
完全的剑道，意味着你不是一直在决斗。新剑道更多是关于你的步法，关于姿势的实际武术，诸如此类。但新剑道最后发生的最大事情是，当你晋升时，你会进行试斩（Tameshigiri）。所以你实际上，你通过等级，你实际上
Have now access to a legit cutting sword I think they're called shinkans Like you have a Ido. It's a blunted blade for kind of test swings, but everything you're right going back to what you said Joel that the the whole thing of Visualizing the sword is not the biggest thing. It's visualizing what's past. It's kind of like hunting. Like you look at your target,
现在可以使用合法的切割剑，我想它们叫真剑（Shinken）。你有居合道。它是一种钝刃，用于测试挥动，但正如你所说，乔尔，可视化剑并不是最重要的事情。最重要的是可视化过去。这有点像打猎。你看着你的目标，
but you also look what's beyond the target. And same thing with the sword. If you think about cutting the thing in front of you, your sword is always gonna get stuck in the thing in front of you. If you thought about how your blade just transcends through the thing in front of you, you let it flow. So Tosh McGeary is crazy. I never got to, I'll be honest, I never got to full on Tosh McGeary. I was able to practice indoors and not
但你也看着目标之外的东西。剑也是一样。如果你想的是切开面前的东西，你的剑总是会卡在面前的东西里。如果你想的是你的刀刃如何穿透面前的东西，你让它流动。所以试斩很疯狂。老实说，我从来没有达到完全的试斩。我能够在室内练习，而不是
necessarily go practice at the Cherry Blossom Festival in Mount Brook. But if you go there, you'll actually see on the stage every year in the Jared Blossom Festival the Shinkendo people doing Tosh McGeary, which is awesome, which started in test cutting. The helm splitting cut is the big thing that you learn because it was the thing that could kind of stripe through iron helmets at the time. And so when you get so good with following, the sword is a slicing instrument and not necessarily beating you up with it. So that was the whole thing is like,
一定要去山布鲁克的樱花节练习。但如果你去那里，你每年都会在樱花节的舞台上看到新剑道的人进行试斩，这很棒，它始于测试切割。劈盔切是你可以学到的重要东西，因为它是当时可以切开铁头盔的东西。所以当你变得非常擅长跟随，剑是一种切割工具，而不是一定要用它来打人。所以整个事情就是，
you had to make your sword slide through time and space through your opponent and that's, or whatever you're cutting and it just goes like that. But you have to think about that. You have to psych yourself up. If you think, oh my gosh gosh am I gonna cut through this? To Tommy Matt, which is what you use in Tosh McGarry You've already lost you have to think about how you're gonna go through this thing and it's a lot of just again
你必须让你的剑通过你的对手在时间和空间中滑动，这就是，或者无论你切什么，它就这样过去了。但你必须考虑这一点。你必须让自己振作起来。如果你想，天哪，我能切开这个吗？榻榻米垫，这就是你在试斩中使用的，你已经输了。你必须考虑你将如何穿过这个东西，这又是一次
That's what the cuts and everything you do is you are trying to flow through it And it's all about just allowing yourself to calm if you have a terrible grip if you're too You know anxious and holding onto their sword, you're gonna feel that sword's weight in your hands a lot more. If you, for a second, you think about how I'm gonna swing this, and depending on what cut,
这就是你所做的切法和一切，你试图流过它。这完全是关于允许自己冷静。如果你有糟糕的握力，如果你太焦虑，抓着剑，你会感觉到剑在手中的重量更多。如果你有一秒钟，你考虑我将如何挥动它，取决于什么切法，
the more mind games that you play with yourself, the more you're gonna lose. Yeah, the idea of emptiness, of zen, of flow state. We talk about artists and intuitives and trying to help patients tell the difference between their own kind of unconscious biases and trauma and flow state of intuition on here a ton. I mean, I think there's so much rich there to mind. Before we get into like the, some of the history of the warriors, duelists, and the specific schools of the forgers in Japan, I was wondering if, Alice, if you have anything about the nature of swords or any of that. I don't know if you've ever looked at the death poem tradition. There's a really good
你玩的心理游戏越多，你输得就越多。是的，空性、禅宗、心流状态的概念。我们在这里谈论艺术家和直觉者，并试图帮助患者区分他们自己的无意识偏见、创伤和直觉的心流状态。我的意思是，我认为这里有很多丰富的内容可以挖掘。在我们进入战士、决斗者和日本锻造流派的历史之前，我想知道，爱丽丝，你对剑的本质有什么看法吗？我不知道你是否看过死亡诗歌传统。有一本很好的
book that I had for a long time. I think that it's disappeared from our waiting room at some point. But there's like a book of Japanese death poetry that like Zen monks would meditate and then come up with a death poem like during the last days of their life that are hakus. They're very short and they're really pretty. I mean some of my favorites are like you know there's a guy that wrote one when he dies in a battle. You know they find it you know he says something about like you know, there's a guy that wrote one when he dies in a battle, you know, they find it, you know, he says something about like, you know, this is a field of warriors. We are icicles melting, returning to the stream, you know,
书，我保存了很长时间。我想它在某个时候从我们的候诊室消失了。但有一本日本死亡诗集，禅僧们会冥想，然后在生命的最后几天写出一首死亡诗，也就是俳句。它们非常短，而且非常漂亮。我的意思是，我最喜欢的一些是，你知道，有一个人在战斗中死去时写了一首。你知道，他们发现了它，你知道，他说了一些关于，你知道，有一个人在战斗中死去时写了一首，你知道，他们发现了它，你知道，他说了一些关于，你知道，这是一个战士的领域。我们是融化的冰柱，回归溪流，你知道，
just so simple. But, and then there's another about like your whole life, you are a ship in a river, a paper doll drifting in a river that a child has dropped, but eventually the river reaches the sea. That kind of idea of energy and continuity that you find in a lot of those traditions. Alice, you do tarot.
如此简单。然后还有另一首关于你的一生，你是一条河里的一艘船，一个孩子掉进河里的纸娃娃，但最终河流到达了大海。你在许多传统中发现的那种能量和连续性的想法。爱丽丝，你做塔罗牌。
I know there's a suite of swords. There's also probably a lot of overlap with swords and esoteric magic. Yeah. I mean, I think, yeah. And everything James is saying just directly flows. I mean, you're talking about energy and how. And it is implicit, like what swords represent
我知道有一套剑牌。剑与深奥魔法之间可能也有很多重叠。是的。我的意思是，我认为，是的。詹姆斯所说的一切都直接流动。我的意思是，你在谈论能量以及如何。它是隐含的，就像剑所代表的
and what the history of it. And especially listening to you all talk about it, swords isn't necessarily. Swords and metallurgy are not one of my special interests. But I am. It's fascinating to hear you all talk about the history and what James is talking about with, you know, how you direct energy and the sword being an extension of you. And so swords are representative of air energy in our, you know, air, water, and air when,
以及它的历史。特别是听你们谈论它，剑不一定。剑和冶金不是我的特殊兴趣。但我确实。听你们谈论历史以及詹姆斯所说的关于你如何引导能量以及剑是你自己的延伸，这很迷人。所以剑在我们的，你知道，空气、水和空气中代表空气能量，当，
I mean, air, water, earth, fire, what am I talking about either? But they represent air energy. And so they always are about clarity and logic and intellect and it's sort of the left side of the brain, the part of your brain that kind of focuses and uses that precision to be able to come to, to be able to like create thoughts instead of just amorphous feelings.
我的意思是，空气、水、土、火，我在说什么？但它们代表空气能量。所以它们总是关于清晰、逻辑和智力，这是大脑的左侧，你大脑中那种专注并利用这种精确性来产生思想而不是仅仅是无定形感觉的部分。
It's like that sharpness of swords. That's the air energy that comes in. So yeah, they represent. And so then just in general, that's kind of what we get with swords. And then, yes, within the tarot, that's what the suit represents. And so with with tarot, it's sort of a, it's a, you put down the the cards and then you then you kind of reflect on like what they bring up for you subconsciously and they all have themes and archetypes and swords is one of the four suits masculine divine masculine energy coming in. So like the Yang energy coming in and that being like using your energy to like penetrate or externalize everything, which is what you're saying like in battle with what you have to do is sort of like, not only is it like dialing dialing in and grounding and like becoming one with the energy, but it's about turning your internal shield outwards and externalizing and putting all of your energy outwards
就像剑的锋利。那是进入的空气能量。所以是的，它们代表。所以总的来说，这就是我们从剑中得到的。然后，是的，在塔罗牌中，这就是这套牌所代表的。所以对于塔罗牌，它是一种，你放下牌，然后你反思它们在潜意识中为你带来了什么，它们都有主题和原型，剑是四套牌之一，男性神圣男性能量进入。所以就像阳性能量进入，那就像利用你的能量来穿透或外化一切，这正是你所说的，就像在战斗中你必须做的那样，不仅仅是像拨号、接地并与能量合一，而是关于将你的内部盾牌向外转，外化并将你所有的能量向外投射，
so that you're not, and that's what you have to do to be able to engage in a battle, is put everything out. And I'm also thinking about Athamas or Ath in like ceremonial magic or some traditions where they're, it looks like a sword, it's like a knife-like thing. You don't use it to actually cut anything or do anything like satanic or something, but it's used to direct energy in ceremonial magic.
这样你就不会，这就是你为了能够参与战斗所必须做的，把一切都放出来。我也在想仪式魔法或某些传统中的Athamas或Ath，它看起来像一把剑，它像一把刀一样的东西。你不用它来真正切任何东西或做任何像撒旦教之类的东西，但它被用来在仪式魔法中引导能量。
And so it would be made of some kind of metal. It has like a double edge, which represents the polarity of the masculine and the feminine. And within ceremony, you might use it to hold, and as you're saying, an extension of yourself to point the energy out and direct it and put your intentions outwards. And they usually have like a black candle, which is all about like neutralizing energy
所以它将由某种金属制成。它有一个双刃，代表男性和女性的极性。在仪式中，你可能会用它来保持，正如你所说，你自己的延伸，指向能量并引导它，把你的意图向外投射。它们通常有一根黑色的蜡烛，这完全是关于中和能量
and grounding it. So yeah, yeah. But I think, yeah, that, and then the metal itself actually like represent is sort of divine masculine representing too. That's like the, in the evolution of the planet, like when the metals came in,
并将其接地。所以是的，是的。但我认为，是的，那，然后金属本身实际上代表是神圣男性，也代表着。这就像，在行星的进化中，当金属出现时，
that was like when consciousness started to be, to pierce the veil with the sharpness of those, it's all like this energy representation. Well, and it is one of the first things that we do to demarcate society that went from sort of a nomadic pre-conscious or pre-collective consciousness. Yeah, no, and that's spot on.
那就像意识开始用那些东西的锋利来刺穿面纱，这都是这种能量表现。嗯，这是我们用来划分社会的第一件事，从某种游牧的前意识或前集体意识。是的，不，这很准确。
Early iron stuff. And Buddhism has some of that too, that's used for like cleaving, piercing, or scraping, but in a metaphorical way. I mean, some of those may be based on old tools. There's like the Kodaga sword or the Purva dagger or the there's a Kartika in my office which is like an old like leather scraper but it's they're so ornate now you couldn't actually use them for that purpose they just have this ritual significance. Like you're saying you couldn't do a satanic sacrifice with any of these things they're too ornate. Like the the Buddhist fire swords have all this metal, you know fire basically around the blade To get to reinforce that this is a spiritual purpose not a metaphorical purpose
早期的铁制品。佛教也有一些，用于切割、穿刺或刮擦，但以隐喻的方式。我的意思是，其中一些可能基于旧工具。我的办公室里有Kodaga剑或Purva匕首，或者有一个Kartika，它就像一个旧的皮革刮刀，但它们现在太华丽了，你实际上无法将它们用于那个目的，它们只是具有这种仪式意义。就像你说的，你不能用这些东西中的任何一个进行撒旦祭祀，它们太华丽了。就像佛教的火剑有所有的金属，你知道，火基本上围绕着刀刃，以加强这是一个精神目的，而不是一个隐喻目的。
Well, and what you're just saying about like the Iron Age and stuff like that sort of I want to I want to just emphasize that It's really interesting and like Eastern traditions and when you understand like consciousness that the whole What you're talking about about the Iron Age coming in, that is literally why, it was like the air energy coming into the evolution of consciousness and that's why those metal ages started happening and we're moving through these different yugas, which are like eras of time. And so that's like metals and swords and stuff
嗯，你刚才说的关于铁器时代之类的事情，我想强调一下。这非常有趣，就像东方传统中，当你理解意识时，你所谈论的铁器时代到来，那字面上就是为什么，它就像空气能量进入意识的进化，这就是为什么那些金属时代开始发生，我们正在经历这些不同的时代（Yugas），它们就像时间的纪元。所以这就像金属和剑之类的东西
are representative of this resurgence of the divine masculine energy coming in and creating more thought forms and societies and systems and organizing things and things that penetrate energy outwards. Which is partly why when I think we become nostalgic for another time, either in a healthy way or in a bad way that can be kind of a fascist or mythologizing like a past we can't return to. This sword is an image that we come back to, in good and bad ways and healthy and unhealthy ways
代表了这种神圣男性能量的复苏，进入并创造了更多的思想形式、社会和系统，组织事物以及向外穿透能量的事物。这就是为什么我认为当我们怀念另一个时代时，无论是健康的还是坏的，那可能是一种法西斯主义或神话化我们无法回归的过去。这把剑是我们回归的形象，以好坏、健康和不健康的方式
through those movements, but not just recently. I mean, even going back to like the Crusades and things, I mean, there were kind of like older calls back to these things, even when the weapons were modern. So the with Japan and the katana, like, I'd like to talk about some of the dualists, and the history of dueling, because I think that shows those tensions like really well. James has some stuff on that. And one of the things I think is interesting is like, you think of the stereotype with
通过这些运动，但不仅仅是最近。我的意思是，即使回到十字军东征之类的事情，我的意思是，即使武器是现代的，也有一些对这些东西的旧呼唤。所以对于日本和武士刀，我想谈谈一些决斗者和决斗的历史，因为我认为这很好地展示了那些张力。詹姆斯在这方面有一些东西。我认为有趣的一点是，你认为刻板印象是
these things is that, you know, the warrior meditates on the sword and thinks of himself as already dead so that if he does die, he's not afraid of it. He's just in flow state, awaking from a dream and that you're really cultivating this inward power by developing character, developing consciousness, developing knowledge, and then the sword becomes this extension of you.
这些东西是，你知道，战士冥想剑，认为自己已经死了，这样如果他真的死了，他就不怕了。他只是处于心流状态，从梦中醒来，你通过培养品格、培养意识、培养知识来真正培养这种内在力量，然后剑成为你自己的延伸。
We think about it in that disciplined way of that you have to train for a hundred years before you can even cut the mat or, you know, a lot of people like to say, well, you could forge a sword in four years, but it took 15 years to know how to polish one and these different kinds of things from different periods of Japan.
我们以那种纪律严明的方式思考它，你必须训练一百年才能切开垫子，或者，你知道，很多人喜欢说，好吧，你可以在四年内锻造一把剑，但需要15年才能知道如何抛光一把，这些来自日本不同时期的不同东西。
But a lot of these duelists were tricksters who were kind of gnarly and kind of defied tradition. Like a lot of the people who were the most successful actually broke their tradition and started to use like the walk is Oshie, the short sword. They would do a dual sword technique or they would do something that wasn't quote unquote allowed. And so like that's sort of an innovative tension, James, you want to, you want to jump in there?
但这些决斗者中有很多是骗子，他们有点古怪，有点蔑视传统。像许多最成功的人实际上打破了他们的传统，开始使用胁差（Wakizashi），短剑。他们会进行双剑技术，或者他们会做一些不被允许的事情。所以这是一种创新张力，詹姆斯，你想加入吗？
Well, I was going to start off with obviously Musashi as the stereotype trickster, Ronin's creating his own path, creating his own sword style. I want to dispel the first things about it that Yoshikawa wrote the books that it internally became Musashi's novel, which books that it internally became Musashi's novel, which influenced the samurai trilogy that we get as movie form. But one, Musashi did not fight for the losing side of the big Tokugawa, and he fought for Tokugawa during those days. So he fought for the winning side. Yoshikawa writes that Musashi fought for the losing side, but that's fiction that wanted to kind of derive
嗯，我本来想从武藏作为刻板的骗子开始，浪人开辟自己的道路，创造自己的剑术风格。我想消除关于它的第一件事，吉川英治写的书，它在内部成为了武藏的小说，这影响了我们作为电影形式看到的武士三部曲。但是，武藏并没有为德川幕府的失败一方而战，他在那些日子里为德川而战。所以他为胜利的一方而战。吉川写道武藏为失败的一方而战，但那是小说，想要推导
the character of Musashi and defeat. But Musashi probably did not experience a lot of defeats, is what we know. That he was 16 when he would be fighting in those wars, which is crazy. Just think like he would have to go fight his dad. Yeah, I love the Musashi, the book Musashi by Yoshikawa. But it definitely took some liberties on how how Musashi came to be. What we do know is that he did follow a Buddhist monk that told him,
武藏的性格和失败。但我们所知道的是，武藏可能没有经历过很多失败。他在16岁时就会在那些战争中战斗，这很疯狂。试想一下，他必须去和他父亲战斗。是的，我喜欢吉川英治的《武藏》。但它确实在武藏是如何形成的方面采取了一些自由。我们所知道的是，他确实跟随了一位佛教僧侣，告诉他，
you've got to reborn, you got to be born again in some way. And that's when he went from, I forgot this originally, I think it's to Takezo was his like born name and then he changed to Miyamoto Mushashi. But that's what started his journey. So he is a trickster. A lot of, again, this is the kind of juxtaposition of samurai versus the Ronin, A lot of, again, this is the kind of juxtaposition of samurai versus the Ronin, which are just wandering samurai, which are that which is kind of a class that was like you either had a bad master that died, or your master didn't, you know, have anybody succeed him in such a way. And so there's always you know, that's what the Ronin type was, but you're still kind
你必须重生，你必须以某种方式重生。那就是他从，我最初忘了这个，我想是Takezo是他的出生名，然后他改名为宫本武藏。但这就是他旅程的开始。所以他是一个骗子。很多，同样，这是武士与浪人之间的并置，浪人只是流浪的武士，这是一种阶级，就像你要么有一个死去的坏主人，要么你的主人没有，你知道，让任何人继承他。所以总是，你知道，这就是浪人的类型，但你仍然有点
of in essence, a samurai, you still follow this type of, this living again, we saw she did write. He was an artist. He reflected a lot. We have a lot of his thoughts on paper. But only after he was done, you know, he sort of basically duels everyone who was around and kills them or wins and then says, all right, there's no one left to fight. Everyone else is younger and they're gonna study me. So I'm gonna kind of go into a cave and write the book of the five rings.
本质上，是一个武士，你仍然遵循这种类型，这种再次生活，我们看到武藏确实写了。他是一位艺术家。他反思了很多。我们在纸上有他很多想法。但只有在他完成后，你知道，他基本上与周围的每个人决斗并杀死他们或获胜，然后说，好吧，没有人可以战斗了。其他人更年轻，他们会研究我。所以我打算去一个洞穴里写《五轮书》。
Yeah, but he also even during his journeys, he had to figure out he wanted to find out why he's going. I mean, that was the whole point of and that's just to the book is fun. Why does he feel, you know, why does he longing for all these things? It wasn't the glory. It wasn't the battle. He just wanted to find what was gonna make him Kind of feel whole again. And so he had to incorporate a lot But you know, he's obviously a very interesting character you if you've read anything about me Sasha you've like he was crafty, very wily in that sense of making people late. He was intentionally late to a lot of his duels,
是的，但他即使在旅途中，也必须弄清楚他为什么要出发。我的意思是，这就是整本书的意义所在，而且这让书变得很有趣。他为什么会有这种感觉，你知道，为什么他会渴望所有这些东西？那不是为了荣耀，也不是为了战斗。他只是想找到能让他重新感到完整的东西。所以他必须融入很多东西，但你知道，他显然是一个非常有趣的角色，如果你读过任何关于宫本武藏的东西，你就会知道他在让人们迟到这方面非常狡猾，非常诡计多端。他故意在很多决斗中迟到，
making, you know, that he was causing that inner karma. There's a trickster psychology to him. To psych people out? Okay. Yeah, like in the book of the five rings, or in the samurai trilogy that James is talking about, you know, spoilers for, you know, the 50 year old
制造出一种内在的因果报应。他有一种骗子的心理。为了让人们心理崩溃？对。是的，就像在《五轮书》中，或者在詹姆斯提到的武士三部曲中，你知道，剧透预警，针对那部50年前的
Japanese cinema, but like he went though one of the last tools of dual and Ganesh, you're island He he shows up late with a or that he's chopped into a sword that he says he's gonna fight with Instead of his real sword to kind of be like I don't even need a sword to defeat you He shines the light from the blade in the guy's eyes. He gets behind the sun. He stands in the water. He goes late to it. He appears to be maybe hungover or just like waking up from a nap, not caring.
日本电影，但他去参加最后一场决斗之一时，在严流岛，他迟到了，或者他带着一把用船桨削成的剑，他说他要用这把剑来战斗，而不是用他真正的剑，这就像是说“我甚至不需要剑就能打败你”。他用刀刃反射的光照进对方的眼睛。他背对着太阳。他站在水里。他迟到了。他看起来可能宿醉未醒，或者只是刚从午睡中醒来，毫不在意。
He does all these things to kind of enrage the opponent that you don't associate with the noble samurai meditating and then killing in a single slice. The most effective duelists really didn't do that. And when I forget the trans, I don't know the original Japanese for the style of swordsmanship that Musashi said he was doing,
他做所有这些事情是为了激怒对手，这与人们印象中那种冥想并在单次挥刀中杀人的高尚武士形象完全不同。最有效的决斗者确实不会那样做。当我忘记那个术语时，我不知道武藏所说的剑术风格的原始日语是什么，
but a lot of those translations are something akin to doing what works or doing whatever it takes or doing what is effective, you know, is kind of how he called his school of swordsmanship. And that a lot of that trickster innovative stuff is sort of at tension with the way that the tradition needs to live in the Japanese culture as being this timeless thing that is about nobility.
但很多翻译类似于“做有效的事”、“不择手段”或“做有用的事”，你知道，这就是他称呼自己剑术流派的方式。那种骗子式的创新与日本文化中传统所要求的——即作为一种关于高尚的永恒事物——之间存在着张力。
But a lot of these guys were kind of gnarly like James is pointing out. They did some psychological trickery and low forms of honor, you know. His style was called the school of the strategy of two heavens as one, which is wild. But yeah, going back to Mutashi again, he was crafty. One of his other famous duels was the final head of this one swordsman dojo is a young kid, probably 12 or 13. Musashi has already defeated I think the heads of this school once and so it's transferred down to
但正如詹姆斯指出的那样，这些人中的许多人都很古怪。他们使用了一些心理诡计和低级的荣誉手段。他的流派被称为“二天一流”，这太疯狂了。但回到武藏身上，他确实很狡猾。他另一场著名的决斗是面对一个剑术道场的年轻掌门，大概12或13岁。武藏之前已经击败过这个流派的掌门，所以它传给了
this kid who follows a family of swordsman in this dojo and of course the school just wants to jump Musashi and so Musashi just sits in a tree and just watches as they all gather Takes note and just like okay This is gonna be easy and all and this is one of the one of the only times in kind of his life that he Actually used one sword and one his actual bladed weapon. You see him all the time So confident and his skill that's the whole confidence he beats people up with boken or wooden bokdos that he carves or finds and sticks that he carves into a sword but this was the one time he's sitting in a tree just watching everybody gather he's knowing he's going to be
这个孩子，他跟随这个道场的武士家族，当然，这个流派的人只想围攻武藏，所以武藏只是坐在树上看着他们聚集，记下一切，心想“好吧，这会很容易”。这是他一生中为数不多的几次真正使用一把剑，使用他真正的带刃武器。你总是看到他对自己技能的自信，这就是那种自信，他用木刀或他雕刻的木棍来击败人们，但这是唯一一次他坐在树上看着每个人聚集，他知道他会被
ambushed but to end the fight quickly he just jumps down sprints draws his sword and chops a little kid in half right off the bat and then just runs away, beats a couple of people up on his way out. Doesn't kill anybody else. I don't think I think he might have killed a couple of other people, but that was the quickest way to end the battle. He knew his target. He knew it wasn't, you know, he's like, he's there to only defeat one person
伏击，但为了迅速结束战斗，他只是跳下来，冲刺，拔剑，直接把那个小孩子劈成两半，然后就跑开了，在离开的路上还打倒了几个人。他没有杀其他人。我不认为……我想他可能杀了其他几个人，但那是结束战斗最快的方法。他知道他的目标。他知道这并不是，你知道，他只是为了击败一个人，
and not defeat 20, which and so he just runs sprints right in as like a crazy person, everybody kind of steps back and is like, what's going on here thinking that he would just line up and face, but instead he did what he had to and just ran and. Well, and there's some speculation that he was like an incredibly strong guy and that he just had a lot more upper body strength than a lot of other people.
而不是击败20个人，所以他就像个疯子一样冲了进去，每个人都退缩了，心想“这是怎么回事”，以为他会排好队面对面，但他做了他必须做的事，直接跑了。嗯，还有一些猜测说他是一个非常强壮的人，他的上半身力量比很多人都大。
And then also maybe he had a skin condition that isolated him or kept him like at the edges of society and not allowed into traditional, and that's a theory until he became so good at sword fighting that he was he had to be like entered into canon. I don't know if you can say anything about that because Miyamoto Sashi and Sasuke Kohiro, those are like the two duelists in Japan that are kind of famous that actually are rooted in real people that are mostly real even though we don't know everything about them. Even the people that had a root in history, like a lot of them turn into kind of myths like Zetaishi the Blind Swordsman. And then the opponent that the last opponent that Miyamoto Musashi faces, even though there's not really a lot of history to it. Like he has an odachi as a longer sword,
还有可能他有一种皮肤病，这让他与世隔绝，或者让他处于社会的边缘，无法进入传统，这是一种理论，直到他变得如此擅长剑术，以至于他不得不被纳入正典。我不知道你能不能说些什么，因为宫本武藏和佐佐木小次郎，这两个是日本比较出名的决斗者，他们确实植根于真实存在的人，即使我们不知道关于他们的所有事情。即使是那些有历史根源的人，很多人也变成了某种神话，比如盲剑客座头市。然后是宫本武藏面对的最后一个对手，尽管关于他并没有太多的历史记载。他有一把大太刀，一把更长的剑，
and he kind of becomes a character that is depicted as like extremely feminine and sometimes almost like, you know, transsexual or transgender in appearance. Do you know why that is? Like I always thought that it was just like a compensation to Miyamoto Mushashi's like masculinity, that he was like such a hyper masculine guy that they portray his final opponent as more feminine.
他变成了一个被描绘成极其女性化，有时甚至在外观上看起来像跨性别者的角色。你知道为什么吗？我一直认为这只是对宫本武藏阳刚之气的补偿，因为他是一个如此极度阳刚的人，所以他们把他的最终对手描绘得更女性化。
But I don't know if there's any historical reason for any of that, really. I don't know. Obviously, that goes back to a lot of people painting Musashi as rambunctious. I think they made up these stories of a skin condition and things like that to kind of make him seem more relatable in a sense, you know, because he was actually really good.
但我不知道这背后是否有任何历史原因。我不知道。显然，这可以追溯到很多人把武藏描绘成一个粗鲁的人。我认为他们编造了关于皮肤病之类的故事，是为了让他看起来更亲切，你知道，因为他实际上真的很厉害。
Again, a lot of people want to paint him as a failure at the beginning, but he probably wasn't. He probably just had, he was good martial ability, which means like his attributes in other areas probably weren't so great. I mean, how he related to other people, especially in writing was just so bizarre. And thinking that, I mean, he ends up feeling normal, but you get to this point where he, when he's not normal,
再说一次，很多人想把他描绘成一个失败者，但他可能并不是。他可能只是有很好的武术能力，这意味着他在其他方面的属性可能并不那么好。我的意思是，他与他人相处的方式，特别是在写作方面，真是太古怪了。而且认为，我的意思是，他最终感觉很正常，但你到了这一点，当他不正常时，
he's a really good dualist, and someone has, they have to point something out, or they're, kind of come up with a reason why he's a bad guy in some essence, right? You know, he's, he can't just be all good. a bad guy in some essence, right? You know, he's, he can't just be all good. And so yeah, you have these things that he does this because he's he isolates himself. He's trying to battle a lot of these things or figure out but it's really, I think he just really wanted to find something that made him feel great. And I'm pretty sure he, the priest Sasaki was his last, I think that was the last duel. I, he used to Odachi and it was because he was paid. Uh, I think that's rooted in him being that a feminine, he, it was probably more so, um,
他是一个非常好的决斗者，有人必须指出这一点，或者他们必须想出一个理由，为什么他在某种本质上是个坏人，对吧？你知道，他不可能全是好的。所以，是的，你有这些事情，他这样做是因为他孤立了自己。他试图与许多这些事情作斗争或弄清楚，但我认为他只是真的想找到能让他感觉很棒的东西。我很确定他，那个祭司佐佐木是他的最后一场，我想那是最后一场决斗。我，他用了大太刀，那是因为他被收买了。呃，我认为这植根于他那种女性化，他，这可能更多是，嗯，
flow state of water or he was more traditional dualist than Massashi maybe traditional dualist, but also kind of wealthy. I mean, he, I think he, at this time he's being paid a lot to kind of coerce Musashi into a duel. Again, he was another famous duelist that everybody believed in and had heard of. No one really saw him fight before. They just heard stories. And I think that was also that kind of mindset of like the stories coming before the person of like, yes, this is our savior. Finally, somebody is going to take down Musashi. Here's a lot of money. And so you get that impersonation of like, just think about somebody who has
水的流动状态，或者他可能比武藏更像传统的决斗者，但也很富有。我的意思是，我认为他在这个时候被支付了很多钱来强迫武藏进行决斗。再说一次，他是另一个每个人都相信并听说过的著名决斗者。没有人真正见过他战斗。他们只是听过故事。我认为这也是那种“故事先于人”的心态，就像“是的，这是我们的救世主。终于有人要打倒武藏了。给你很多钱。”所以你得到了那种模仿，就像，想想一个
been on the road as a Ronin for forever. And then someone who's getting actively paid a lot to take care of this problem. You get that kind of sense of this person's wearing a little bit more nice clothes. He's able to hang out with people, trying to figure out where Musashi is. And so I think they paint him in that light of very feminine because he wasn't out there trying to beat people up like, or trying to find the next fight like Musashi was, he was just really, he only one target and that was try to track him down and then trap him.
作为浪人一直在路上的人。然后是一个被积极支付很多钱来解决这个问题的人。你会得到那种感觉，这个人穿着稍微好一点的衣服。他能够和人们混在一起，试图找出武藏在哪里。所以我认为他们把他描绘成那样非常女性化，因为他不像武藏那样在外面试图打人，或者试图寻找下一场战斗，他只是真的，他只有一个目标，那就是试图追踪他，然后困住他。
Um, and that's why Musashi knew that he wasn't about to be trapped. He was going to make sure that he made him pay for this. Um, but after that, I think it wasn't fun for Musashi anymore. I think that was the reason it was one of his last duels was because he had successfully, you never saw him really use his technique on anybody. Again, the wooden oar to the island after the dude's tired is a crazy story.
嗯，这就是为什么武藏知道他不会被困住。他会确保让他付出代价。嗯，但那之后，我认为武藏不再觉得有趣了。我认为这就是为什么这是他最后几场决斗之一的原因，因为他已经成功了，你从来没有真正看到他用他的技术对付任何人。再说一次，在那个家伙累了之后，用木桨在岛上决斗是一个疯狂的故事。
But he carves his own sword and just bops him over the head and crushes his skull apparently But so you get those you get the things you have to find some way to demonize somebody doubles holotail I practiced that with my daughter with her wooden katana hundred She's she's gonna go on a journey soon just start Well, we have a tea party and then a sword fight on the top of Red Mountain So whichever way society goes, you know, she's covered, you know, yeah down to an Abbey or or fall Got all the skills
但他雕刻了自己的剑，只是敲了他的头，显然压碎了他的头骨。但所以你得到了那些，你必须找到某种方式来妖魔化某人。双重尾巴，我和我女儿用她的木制武士刀练习过。她很快就要踏上旅程了。好吧，我们举行了一个茶会，然后在红山顶上进行了一场剑术对决。所以无论社会走向何方，你知道，她都有保障，你知道，是的，直到修道院或者跌倒，拥有了所有的技能。
But yeah, I think that's a but I do think there's a reason why we paint Well, a lot of people that paint me Sasha and so it's sort of way but also hit that The people who came after him in another because he was kind of too perfect So in a sense of he was really good at what he did and then he wrote in another because he was kind of too perfect. So in a sense of he was really good at what he did. And then he wrote great books when he was done. So he's androgynous at the end. Y'all are saying that's like how he how it culminates. And probably not historically, but artistically, if you see people
但是，是的，我认为这是一个原因，但我确实认为我们描绘武藏的方式是有原因的，而且在他之后的人也是如此，因为他太完美了。所以在某种意义上，他所做的事情非常出色，然后他在完成后写了伟大的书。所以他在最后是雌雄同体的。你们都在说这就是它的高潮。可能在历史上不是这样，但在艺术上，如果你看到人们
inspired by him in anime is anything they're almost kind of transgender some of the time or extremely feminine, long hair, long sword. Because that also represents like the ultimate like enlightenment is coming back to androgyny and merging the divine feminine and divine masculine. Well, it's an Eastern religion thing is coming back to that androgyny. I mean, and historical philosophy like Aristotle and stuff, but merging those two and becoming like one with one with Chi one with the universe and then being able to like direct it all so sometimes I don't think it's necessarily I don't know that the
在动漫中受到他的启发，他们有时几乎是跨性别者，或者极其女性化，长发，长剑。因为这也代表了终极的启蒙，回归到雌雄同体，融合了神圣的女性和神圣的男性。嗯，这是一种东方宗教的东西，回归到那种雌雄同体。我的意思是，在历史哲学中，比如亚里士多德之类的，但融合这两者并变得像与气合一，与宇宙合一，然后能够引导这一切，所以有时我不认为这一定是，我不知道
history presents what y'all are telling me but I don't think that like return like a androgyny necessarily indicates like a weakness so much as it might be representative of enlightenment yeah I don't think it's from weakness. I mean, he's usually portrayed as a pretty powerful character sometimes as like either the main antagonist or the main protagonist of like different kind of manga and historical or based on history, you know. Yeah, I think it had a lot to do with wanting external validation versus Musashi's internal validation like Musashi is always searching for this something that's within. And Sasaki was probably the one that's
历史呈现了你们告诉我的东西，但我不认为那种回归到雌雄同体一定代表软弱，它可能代表启蒙。是的，我不认为这是因为软弱。我的意思是，他通常被描绘成一个相当强大的角色，有时是不同类型的漫画和历史或基于历史的作品中的主要反派或主要主角。是的，我认为这与寻求外部验证与武藏的内部验证有很大关系，就像武藏总是寻找内在的某种东西。而佐佐木可能是那个
looking for that external. I'm the one who defeated me. So she that's all he wanted to do. That's all he wanted. But for it's for everybody to know that going through town saying I'm the one that's going to fight me. So she and it's just like, so I don't think remembers his name. Like that's the thing he does. He's just like, Sashi I don't think remembers his name. I like that's the thing he does.
寻找外部验证的人。我是那个击败武藏的人，这就是他想做的。这就是他想要的。但这是为了让每个人都知道，在镇上走来走去说“我是那个要和武藏战斗的人”。这就像，所以我认为没人记得他的名字。就像那是他做的事情。他只是像，武藏我想没人记得他的名字。我喜欢他做的那件事。
He's just like, I don't know who you are, but they say I need to fight you kind of thing. So it's- Yeah, that was another kind of psych trick of being like, I haven't even heard your legend. You know, I don't even know who you are. You know, this guy's been paying people to talk about himself for a long time.
他只是像，我不知道你是谁，但他们说我需要和你战斗之类的。所以是——是的，那是另一种心理诡计，就像“我甚至没听说过你的传说。你知道，我甚至不知道你是谁。这家伙一直在付钱让人谈论他自己，已经很久了。”
Yeah. What about, I mean, I'd like to do an anime episode at some point with a guest, if we find the right guest, but what do you think about the way that swords kind of, or the katana connects with like weebs, like people that kind of like mythologize it and turn it bad maybe, or just, what do you think about that?
是的。关于，我的意思是，我想在某个时候和一个嘉宾做一期动漫节目，如果我们找到合适的嘉宾的话，但你觉得剑，或者武士刀与像“二次元宅”这样的人的联系方式如何，就是那些有点神话它并可能把它变坏的人，或者只是，你对此有什么看法？
Like generally like the cool guy that you were like kind of scared of, but wanted to pretend you could fit in with. In my experience, you know, when you're like in high school or early college, you like it's a little older that drives like a souped up Mitsubishi Eclipse, or has like Bala sharks,
就像通常那种你有点害怕，但想假装你能融入其中的酷家伙。根据我的经验，你知道，当你上高中或大学早期时，你喜欢那种稍微大一点的，开着改装的三菱Eclipse，或者有像巴拉鲨鱼，
or like he was the guy that knew like all the strains of weed where it was like halfway made up, or like all the cool stuff you didn't know from your suburban identity. And like he knew all the katana facts and had the book of five rings on his coffee table. I don't know if y'all had this experience with you know, that was definitely a type of dude. It was. Yeah. Well, even in yeah, 2011, there was a guy like that who actually got me into it. I jokingly, I mean, I watched anime, but you would always see like somebody slice
或者像他是那种知道所有大麻品种的人，虽然那是半编造的，或者所有你从郊区身份中不知道的酷东西。而且他知道所有关于武士刀的事实，并在他的咖啡桌上放着《五轮书》。我不知道你们是否有过这种经历，你知道，那绝对是一种类型的家伙。确实是。是的。好吧，即使在2011年，也有一个那样的家伙，他实际上带我入坑了。我开玩笑地说，我的意思是，我看动漫，但你总是会看到有人像切黄油一样切开某物，它不动，然后慢慢滑落。我亲眼看到那个家伙用西瓜做到了，我就被征服了。我当时想，天哪，他就像进入了这个区域。他就像，这在当时是一个派对把戏。他只是说，“让我们看帕克切这个瓜”，我们就会去他的后廊，他就会进入这个区域。接下来
through something like butter and it doesn't move and then slowly slides off. I saw this guy do that in person with a watermelon and I was sold. I was like, Holy crap, he just like got into this zone. He was like, it was a party trick at this point. He's just like, let's watch Parker, you know, slice up this melon and we would just go outside his back porch and he would just like get into this zone. And the next thing
那些家伙现在，我不知道他们是否成功了。哦，这个家伙成功了。这个家伙。是的。呃，他现在是亚特兰大的百万富翁。所以这很疯狂。呃，所以也许这就是那种专注为他带来的结果。呃，也许我需要回到那种剑道。好。是的。让我们研究一下剑道。所以，它是怎么回事？
those guys are now, I wonder if it worked out for them. Oh, it worked out for this guy. This guy. Yeah. Uh, he's doing, he's, he's a millionaire in Atlanta right now. So it's crazy. Uh, so maybe that's what that focus did for him. Uh, maybe I need to get back into that can do. Good. Yeah. Let's study the study the blade study. So and do what is it? And what does it go?
英雄有那种“无剑”的概念。就像他会做很多战斗，他会说最好的方式是避免战斗。而且你知道，其中一个人嘲笑他，说“我想用你的无剑风格和你决斗”。他说，是的，我会在这个岛上和你决斗。跟我去这个岛。我会给你展示无剑。那家伙说，好的，没问题。他把他划船带到这个偏远的岛上，那家伙下了船，他说，再见。他把他留在那里几天，没有和他决斗。他说，这就是
Hero had that concept of like no sword. Like he would do a lot of the fights where he would say like the best way is to avoid combat. And you know, one of the guys, you know, taunts him and is like, I want to duel you with your no sword style. And he's like, yeah of the guys, you know, taunts him and is like, I want to duel you with your no sword style. And he's like, yeah, I'll do you on this island. Come with me to this island. I'll show you no sword. The guy's like, yeah, fine. And he rose him out to this remote island and the guy gets off the boat and he's like, bye. And he leaves him there for a couple days and doesn't do him. And he's like, that's
你如何进行一点无剑。所以有很多像玩弄能量、骗子文化，你知道，有战斗能力，但也比需要战斗更好，我认为这是你在这些故事中看到的那些大张力之一，那些能量传统呼应了其他深奥的实践。爱丽丝，你看到任何相似之处吗，或者任何东西，因为你提到了使用像爱丽丝，你看到任何相似之处吗？因为你提到在西方深奥魔法中使用刀或剑来分离事物，劈开事物，引导能量。不完全是一根魔杖，但它是一个出现在
how you do a little no sword. So there's a lot of kind of like playing with like energy trickster, you know culture being you know Being capable at fighting but also being better than needing to fight I think is one of those big tensions you see in these stories and those kind of energetic traditions echo like other Esoteric practices and Alice you see any like parallels or or anything because you had to mention using like Alice, do you see any parallels or anything? Because you had mentioned using knives or swords in Western esoteric magic to separate things, cleaving things, directing energy. Not quite a wand, but it is a tool that shows up
传统中的工具。是的，使用方式类似于魔杖。但是的，它可以重定向和引导意图，这就是你试图发出的东西。魔杖，但是的，它可以重定向和引导意图，就像你试图发出的东西一样。而且我认为，你知道，当詹姆斯谈论策略时，你知道，你试图不切断某物，而是像完全切开它，就像你必须非常清楚你的意图，而不是陷入困境。就像你希望你的生活看起来是什么样子的？
in the traditions. Yeah, used in a similar way from a wand. But yeah, it can redirect and direct intention is what you're trying to put out there. a wand, but yeah, it can kind of redirect redirect and direct intention is like what you're what you're trying to put out there. And and I think that's, you know, when James is talking about like the strategy of, you know, you're trying to not cut something but but like fully slice through it, like you have to like get really clear on like, what is your intention and not get bogged down? Like like what do you want your life to look like?
是的，是的。关于塔罗牌象征，剑牌组，任何你提到的空气，但还有其他贯穿线吗，比如在那个牌组中？是的，我的意思是它总是，是的，所以它代表逻辑和清晰，就像我们谈论的那样。很多时候在剑牌组中，塔罗牌里没有坏牌，但剑牌组的牌可能会让人感觉，而且这只是，你需要知道，如果你想学习塔罗牌，如果你做得对，真的没有任何坏牌。
Yeah, yeah um What about tarot symbolism the suite of swords like any of the you had mentioned air um, but are there ways that like the Are there other through lines like in that suite? Yeah, I mean it's always um Yeah, so it rep so like I was saying kind of represents logic and clarity like we're talking about. A lot of times in the sword suit, there are no bad cards in the tarot, but the swords ones can feel and that and that's just like, you need to know that if you want to learn about tarot, there aren't really any bad cards if you're doing it right.
但十号剑牌是一个相当艰难的牌组。它感觉有点像那样。有各种各样的牌，剑牌确实感觉更像是它们在某种程度上，对我来说，代表了不同的创伤之类的东西。可能会有剑的描绘。六号剑牌是一个小家庭，坐在一艘船上，从波涛汹涌的水域移动到更平静的水域。但他们仍然把所有的剑堆在船上。所以这是一种想法，
But the 10 of 10 of swords is kind of tough suit. It sort of feels like that. And there are various cards where the swords do feel more like they're kind of, to me, representing different traumas and things like that. There might be swords depicted. The Six of Swords is a little family that's in a boat moving from rough waters to calmer waters. But they have all these swords still stacked in their boat. And so it's this kind of idea of
他们可能正在离开这片饱受战争蹂躏的土地，但他们带着所有的武器。所以这就像，所以，而且它就像一个父亲，一个母亲和一个孩子。所以这不像是一场战斗，但他们正在搬到更安全的地方，但你知道，无论你带走什么，你学到的教训，就像那些刺穿并劈开你的意识并重定向你的能量的东西，即使在你治愈的时候，也要带着它。
they're maybe leaving this war torn land, but they're taking all these weapons with them. So it's like the, so, so it's, and it's, and it's like a father, a mother, and a child. So it's not like a battle thing, but they're moving somewhere safer, but you know, no matter what you take the lessons that you learned, like the things that pierced and like cleaved your consciousness and like redirected your energy and bringing that, bringing that with you even as you're, as you're healing.
所以有不同的剑，我的意思是，剑牌组，我的意思是，剑牌组中的牌，这就是剑可以被玩弄的方式。焦虑在其中出现了很多，因为这只是刺穿你的意识的东西，试图，你知道，你拥有的知识试图刺穿面纱并进入你的意识，试图像升起进入新的意识和新的。是的。我一直想知道剑，
So there are different, different swords, I mean, suits of swords, like, I mean, cards within the sword suit that kind of, that's kind of how swords can kind of be played with. Anxiety comes up a lot with it because this is just things that are piercing your consciousness of trying to, you know, knowledge that you have that's trying to pierce through the veil and come into your consciousness, trying to like rise up into new awareness and new. Yeah. I always wondered if the sword,
权力的游戏椅子，由剑锻造的椅子或王座，是否不是受到那个牌组的启发，因为他玩弄了很多那种想法，即他们拿着剑并通过把它们做成王座来使它们变得无用，但王座本身就是暴力的和腐败的，它可能会把你带回暴力，以及这种剑的滑溜性质。嗯，我一直想知道马丁是否在玩弄其中的一些想法，或者他只是独立地在《权力的游戏》中得出了这些想法。我认为这很有趣，因为很多时候
the game of thrones chair um chair or throne forged out of swords wasn't inspired by that suite because he plays with a whole lot of that idea that they're taking the swords and making them useless by making them a throne but the throne is so inherently violent and corrupting that it could lead you back into violence and and and this sort of like slippery nature of the sword. Um, I always wondered if Martin was playing with some of those ideas or he just arrived at them independently in Game of Thrones. I think it's interesting because a lot of times
他可能是有意为之，但随后就有了这种，这就是我们回到这些植根于我们意识中的东西，这些我们没有意识到的原型。所以作为一个艺术家或作者，你玩弄并带出这些主题，这些只是这些，你知道，基本知识的普遍片段，你可以在任何地方找到它，即使作者是艺术家，甚至知道他们在做什么。那是因为它来自真理，它在流动中。我知道詹姆斯必须马上离开。你有什么想签名的或者在最后加入的吗？爱丽丝，你现在需要离开吗？
he might have done it intentionally, but then there's just sort of, this is where we get back into these things that are baked into our consciousness, these art types that we don't realize. And so as an artist or an author, you play with and bring out these, these themes that are just these, you know, universal pieces of fundamental knowledge, and you can find it everywhere, even if the author is an artist and even know what they were doing. That's because it's from truth, it's in the flow. I know James has to hop off in a minute. Did you have anything you wanted to sign off or kind of throw in at the end of there? Alice, do you need to get off right now?
还是我们可以多跑一两分钟？是的，我有。好吧，是的，我可以再做几分钟。好的。詹姆斯，你有什么？我没有什么要签名的，除了，好吧，我没有什么要签名的。好吧，谢谢。
Or can we run a minute or two over? Yeah, I have. Well, yeah, I can do a few more minutes. OK. James, what you got? I don't have anything to sign off on except for, well, I don't have anything to sign off on. Well, thank you.
你看到武道学院开业了吗，比如北伯明翰？你想和我一起报名吗？我正在考虑上一些课。真的吗？看它。寻找我的爱。我得去进行真正的艺术治疗了。是的，所以通过它。所以好吧，伙计们。好吧，下周见。再见。是的，我不知道。我有很多关于你所说的东西，或者我的一个朋友在研究生院工作了一会儿，他帮助外国学生参与进来。他告诉我，很多时候来自印度、日本、中国等东方传统的学生，在引用来源这个想法上很困难，因为他们说，好吧，那是永恒的哲学。它是每个人的。它只是宇宙的任何作品。我为什么要写下来？你不能写下第一个想出那个想法的人。而那种西方发明者拥有知识的自我意识，以及无论它是什么，都与那个想法格格不入。这就是你开始，一旦你深入其中，它就开始感觉你有点认识到，哦，这个，你知道，我们把这个归功于50年代的某个人，但这就像3000年前的。有人在3000年前就在这里说了。就像3000年前的，有人在3000年前就在这里说了。是的。而这就是，这就是我对西方科学的抱怨，只是某种
Did you see the Abudo Academy open, like North Birmingham? You want to sign up with me? I was thinking of doing some classes. Really? the it. Look for my love. I gotta go do the real art therapy. Yeah, so through it. So alright guys. Well, next week. See ya. Yeah, I don't know. I was a lot of the stuff with like you're saying, or a friend of mine was what did like graduate school work for a minute where he was like helping foreign students get engaged. And he was like telling me that a lot of times students that are coming from like Eastern traditions of India, Japan, China, like have a hard time with this idea of like citing sources because they're like, well, that's a perniprofesy. It's everybody's. It's just the universe's whatever work. Why would I write down? You can't write down the first time that somebody came up with that. And that kind of egoic idea of like Western inventor owns the knowledge and like whatever it was like,
我们正在识别所有这些东西，它们字面上在，你知道，吠陀经之类的东西里，他们谈论所有的，你知道，量子物理学和一切，我们从不承认，你知道，我们发现了东西，但从不觉得，哦等等，好吧，这一定是他们在这里谈论的东西。就像这就是这位科学家谈论的东西。谁获得荣誉真是太有趣了。就像你说的，为了这些普遍的知识片段。是的，我不，我认为，你知道，如果你发明了轧棉机，或者如果你发明了一种新的抗生素，你可能，你知道，你发明了轧棉机，或者如果你发明了一种新的抗生素，你可能，你知道，
so at odds with that. That's what you start to, once you kind of get deep in it, it just starts to feel like you kind of recognize like, oh, this, you know, we attribute this to somebody from the 50s, but this is like 3000 year old. Somebody said it back here 3000 years ago. like 3000 year old, somebody said it back here 3000 years ago. Yeah. And that is that's that's sort of my beef with like Western science is just sort of
是第一个想出那个分子连接在一起的方式的人，或者类似的东西。但当你回到这些关于能量的软科学中的东西时，你知道，甚至你知道，量子物理学数学在这些高层变得有点软科学。你有什么，你有什么，你有一个拥有所有权或发明权的人吗？我不知道。是的。
where we're kind of identifying all this stuff that's like literally in, you know, the Vedas and stuff you they talk about all the, you know, quantum physics and everything and we never acknowledge, you know, we discover things but never go, oh wait, okay, this is what they must have been talking about back here. Like this is what this scientist was talking about. It's just, it's just interesting who gets the credit. Like you're saying for these like universal pieces of knowledge. Yeah, I don't, I think that, you know, if you invent a cotton gin, or if you invent a new antibiotic, you probably, you know, you invent a cotton gin or if you invent a new antibiotic you probably you know
是的。我不知道。我试图想，我刚才有个想法，但你能多说一点吗？好吧，我不知道。只是，你知道，好吧，好吧，关于永恒哲学，我的意思是，因为我们在这里肯定会碰到很多这种情况。我有点两种想法，因为我通常尝试说，好吧，这是精神传统，
Are the first one to come up with the way that that molecule is connected together or something But when you're coming back to these things that are in softer sciences about uh energy and you know Even you know quantum physics math kind of becomes a soft softer science at these upper levels What do you um? How do you uh, you you have somebody who has ownership or invention of that? I don't know. Yeah.
这是人类学传统，这是在心理学中与它碰撞的传统，然后如果是相关的，或者是与人类学足够分开的，如果是神话，尝试让人们感觉到它。因为我觉得这是说“是的，很多人在这些领域工作过”的最好方式。有办法让它们更具纪律性，但它们的来源是跨学科的。
Yeah. I don't know. I'm trying to think I had a thought back there, but can you say more about that? Well, I don't know. Just, you know, well well with perennial philosophy in general I mean because we definitely bump up against a lot of that on here I'm kind of of two minds because I usually try and say like alright, here's the spiritual tradition
但当我读到做同样事情的作者时，我不喜欢它。就像，我当时想，哦，我明白了，我明白了。我知道那抓住了重点。所以我不知道是否有办法清楚地传达这一点，但我不喜欢它。就像我当时想，哦，我明白了，我明白了。我知道那抓住了重点，你知道，所以我不知道是否有办法清楚地传达这一点。但我不知道。清楚地传达这一点。是的。好吧，而且我认为，是的，有很多，就像即使是发明，具体的发明，就像你谈论的那样，就像历史上有这么多案例表明，多个人在同一时间左右想出了同样的发明或同样的概念。所以它真的就像，有任何人真的在
Here's the anthropology tradition Here's the tradition where that gets bumped up against in psychology and then maybe myth if that's relevant or if it's separate enough from the Anthropology right to try and let people kind of feel it. Because I feel like that's the best way of just kind of saying, yeah, a lot of people have worked in these spheres. There's ways that you can make them more disciplinary, but the source of them is kind of interdisciplinary.
发明某物，还是在对世界如何运作的能量理解中？人们实际上是在利用集体知识，突然间，集体意识把这些碎片放在一起，突然间他们是小个体，碰巧处于正确的频率，能够访问它，然后将其转化为某种发明。所以它总是，你知道，一旦你进入细节，就像，谁真的，当我试图写作时，我进入我的头脑，就像，试图弄清楚如何以没有人说过的方式说事情。然后它就，突然间，它就开始看起来像每一个字都只是别人已经用过的隐喻。而且就像，每一个短语都感觉，感觉陈腐。嗯，感觉陈腐。好吧，而且我认为保持自我的身份，嗯，那是，你知道，个体的，然后也是像集体的，是很难的，你知道，你有点希望那些东西产生共鸣，但你知道，我们确实存在了
But when I read authors that do the same thing that I do, I don't like it. Like, I'm like, oh, I get it, I get it. I know that gets the point. So I don't know if there's like a way to kind of communicate that clearly, but I don't like it. Like I'm like, Oh, I get it. I get it. I know that gets the point, you know, so I don't know if there's like a way to kind of communicate that clearly. But I don't know. Communicate that clearly. Yeah. Well, and I think, yeah, there's a lot to, like even inventions, concrete inventions, like you're talking about, like there's so many cases where in history, it shown that multiple people right around the same time came up with the same invention or the same concept. And so it's really like, is any one person really
一分钟作为世界上的个体。我们用它做什么？你知道，那是一个古老的问题。嗯，是的。而且，呃，我不知道，只是给剑和武士刀的心理学盖上盖子。还有什么你想达到的吗，或者你觉得我们已经尽可能地触及了它？
inventing something or is there in energetic understandings of how the world works? People are actually tapping into collective knowledge that suddenly like put collective consciousness that's put these pieces together and all of a sudden they're little individuals who, like, are happened to be the right frequency to be able to like access it and then transform it into into some kind of invention. So it's kind of always, you know, once you get into the nitty gritty, it's like, who really, like, I get into my head when I try to write, like, like, trying to figure out how to say things in a way that nobody's ever said them. And then it just, all of a sudden, it just starts looking like every single word is just a metaphor that somebody has already used. And like, every phrase is feels, feels trite. Um, feels trite. Well, and I think that holding the identity of the self, um, that is, you know, individual and then also like the collective is, is hard, you know, you kind of want those things to be in resonance, but you know, we do exist for
我觉得我们已经触及了它。是的，我认为只是关于创伤的心理学，加强了剑在塔罗牌中可能代表不同的创伤，以及它是如何直接影响并让我们进入战斗或逃跑，然后让我们保持在那里，它变成了一种有时会以给你这些觉醒或类似东西的方式崩溃你的现实的力量，或者只是深刻的知识，它是剑进来并刺穿你的个体，你所有的神经和一切，它进来并刺穿了所有这一切。可能有一个很好的隐喻可以从基于部分的心理学中做出，就像这个想法，我们注意到自我的所有这些部分和我们的多重性，但当我们把它们放在一起而不过度认同
a minute as an individual in the world. What do we do with that? You know, that's an old question. Um, yeah. And, uh, I don't know, just kind of put a cap on, on, on swords and the psychology of katanas. Is there anything else that you kind of want to get to, or do you feel like we've hit that as much as we can?
一个时，我们实际上比我们部分的总和还要多，就像你堆叠，你知道，脊柱中间的软金属，你知道，中等金属，然后层压成更硬的金属，然后加强尖端以制造马氏体。然后这把整把剑现在可以切开玻璃可以切开的东西，但它不像玻璃那样僵硬。它足够灵活，可以持续战斗。关于钢的折叠和灵魂的锻造可能也有相关之处。是的。那是形成自我的剑。所以这就是我们看到创伤和人们分裂的地方，
I feel like we've hit it. Yeah, I think just with the psychology of trauma to just reinforcing that the swords can represent maybe in the tarot different traumas and how it's these things that directly impact and put us into fight or flight and then keep us there, it becomes this force that can sometimes it collapses your reality in ways that gives you these awakenings or things like that, or just profound knowledge and it's that swords coming in and piercing through your individual, all your neurons and everything, it's coming in and piercing through all of that. There's probably a good metaphor to be made like from parts based psychology, like the idea that like, we're noticing all these parts of self and our multiplicity, but that when we bring them together and don't over identify with
或者只是我们中的任何一个。我认为一切，那也是一个光谱，我们解离了多少，那些剑真的，创伤已经进来并像把我们分裂成不同的部分。而且它是关于，你知道，试图，但试图有点像回来并重新拥有那种能量并回到中心。是的。好吧，就像，你处理的那些与个人力量隔绝的人，他们有点像对自己的代理权或自己的声音认同不足。嗯，很多躯体从业者谈论这一点出现在手臂和胸部中心，
one, we're actually more than the sum of our parts in the same way that you're stacking, you know, like a soft metal in the middle of the spine, you know, a medium metal and then laminating in a harder metal and then reinforcing the tip to make martensite. And then this whole sword can now cut through things that glass can cut through, but it's not as rigid as glass. It's flexible enough to last through the battle. Something probably there about the folding of steel and the forging of the soul also is relevant. Yeah. That is swords that forms the ego. And so that is where we see trauma and people split,
很多时候，当你试图让他们接触到他们的自我权利时，他们会感觉到心脏里有一个黑洞在吸，你知道，你想要用温暖或光来代替它，你知道，有点冥想那种力量的感觉。但我的意思是，那确实是战士原型。当你拿着剑时，你拿着它，你知道，手臂在胸前。而且当我说“好吧，你过度认同了魔术师，你试图把一切都理解为塔罗牌，你试图把一切都理解为一个系统”时，很多人
or just any of us. I think everything, that's on a spectrum as well, how much we're dissociating, how much those swords have really, the traumas have come in and like split us into different parts. And it's about, you know, trying to, but trying to kind of like come back and re and like own that energy and come back to center even. Yeah. Well, like, uh, people you deal with that have been cut off from personal power that are sort of like under identified with their own agency or their own voice. Um, a lot of somatic practitioners talk about that showing up across the arms and in the center of the chest,
并且被动地，但你需要对你的能力更舒服，你知道，因为创伤，你被切断了这种能力，只是说，这是我，我是可见的，我有权进行这次对话，我有权拥有自我并站直，你你知道让人们接触到那个战士原型。是的，他们中的很多人想象自己拿着剑或拿着盾牌。是的，在像哈他瑜伽和昆达里尼瑜伽和不同的练习中，
that a lot of times when you try and get them in touch with like their right to self, they feel a black hole sucking, you know, in the heart, and you want to replace that with like a warmth or light and, you know, kind of meditate on that feeling of power. But I mean that is kind of the warrior archetype. When you're holding a sword, you're holding it, you know, with your arms in front of your chest. And a lot of the people when I'm saying, okay, you're really over-identified with the magician, you're trying to understand everything as a terry, you're trying to understand everything as a system
我最喜欢的一些在昆达里尼瑜伽传统中，你把你的手臂像那样放上去，然后那是，就像你的手指有点指向房间的边缘。但然后保持它，你保持它三分钟，你知道，任何地方到11分钟左右，取决于多少。但它基本上是，但有趣的是，当你保持它时，想法是你的肩膀真的，你的肩膀和手臂真的足够强壮，让你在那个时间内做到这一点。但发生了一种心理上的事情，它只是开始感觉像，我不能这样做，肩膀，无力感，之类的东西。所以当你冥想这些姿势时，
and passively, but you need to be more comfortable with your ability, you know, because of trauma, you've been cut off from this ability to just say, this is me, I'm visible, I have a right to this conversation, I have a right to self and standing upright, you you know getting people in touch with that warrior archetype Yeah, a lot of them imagine themselves holding a sword or holding a shield Yeah, and in like Hatha yoga and Kundalini yoga and different practices
另一个是像你，让我退后，然后我会回到我，但你像那样向上，我像这样在顶部拿着它。但那就像达伦，你把你的手指直接向上，你只是完全集中你的能量并向下推入地球，就像在顶部向上引导。所以你正在制造你的，你只是完全集中你的能量并向下推入地球，就像在顶部向上引导。
some of my favorite in Kundalini yoga tradition you put your Put your arms up like that and and then that's, and like with your fingers kind of pointing to the edge of the room. But then hold it, you hold it like that for three minutes to, you know, anywhere to like 11 minutes or something, depending on how much. But it's basically, but what's interesting is that as you're holding it, the idea is that your shoulders are really, your shoulders and your arms are really strong enough to let you do that for that amount of time. But there's this psychological thing that happens where it just starts feeling like, like, I can't do this on our shoulders, powerlessness, things like that. And so as you meditate in some of these postures,
在昆达里尼瑜伽传统中，我最喜欢的一些动作是把双臂像那样举起来，手指指向房间的边缘。然后保持这个姿势三分钟，甚至长达11分钟左右，具体取决于你的承受能力。有趣的是，当你保持这个姿势时，你的肩膀和手臂必须足够强壮才能坚持那么久。但在这个过程中会产生一种心理反应，你会开始觉得“我做不到，我的肩膀受不了”，产生一种无力感。所以，当你保持这些姿势进行冥想时，
another one is like where you, let me back up and then I'll come back to me, but where you're like up like that, and I'm holding it like this up at the top. But that's like Daren, you hold your fingers directly up and you're just completely concentrating your energy and pushing down into the earth and like directing up at the top. And so you're making your and you're just completely concentrating your energy and pushing down into the earth and like directing up at the top.
另一个动作是这样的，让我退后一点再回到原位，就像这样，我把手举在头顶。这就像是达伦（Daren）所说的，手指直指上方，你完全集中精力，向下推向大地，同时向上引导能量。你正在塑造你的身体，完全集中你的能量，向下推向大地，并向上引导。
And so you're making your, you're doing the same thing with your body to be able to direct the energy, turning yourself into like that sword, sword sorta. Is the arms up, is that what you call sun salutation or is that something different? That's different in these types of, in Hatha yoga and Kundalini. I can't remember what we call it.
所以你正在做同样的事情，用你的身体来引导能量，把自己变成像那把剑一样。手臂向上举起，这就是所谓的拜日式吗？还是别的什么？在哈他瑜伽和昆达里尼瑜伽中，那是不同的。我不记得我们管它叫什么了。
I can't remember what that's, it's in a bunch of kriyas, but I can't remember what it's called. Yeah, nuts. the You know, that's that's interesting I think that and that idea of kind of like power being in the center the warrior archetype You know being kind of identified with the sword that we have a right to our own kind of individual voice or power We come back to that In a lot of different somatic traditions because it is the way that you assert individual power, you know Whereas like there's a lot of kind of more mystical pathways and to understand things intuitively, but the sword is not really about as intuition
我不记得那是什么了，它出现在很多克里亚（kriyas）练习中，但我记不起它的名字。是的，太疯狂了。你知道，这很有趣，我认为那种力量存在于中心、战士原型的概念，你知道，与剑的认同，意味着我们有权拥有属于自己的个人声音或力量。我们在许多不同的躯体传统中都会回到这一点，因为这是你主张个人力量的方式。虽然有很多更神秘的途径去直观地理解事物，但剑并不是真正关于直觉的。
as much as being able to actualize something. Yeah. And it's about, yeah, what you're saying in swords, I guess what I didn't, the keyword here is also swords, you're about truth. And so when I'm showing you like, and you could do this, anyone could do this, but sit in lotus or sit crouching on your knees
它更多是关于能够实现某事。是的。关于你说的剑，我想我没提到的是，这里的关键词也是剑，你代表的是真理。所以当我向你展示时，任何人都可以这样做，盘腿坐着或跪着。
and do the one where you're holding your arms, your fingers like this. And this is a mudra that I can't remember the name of. And then you hold your, but hold your arms up. That one, as you're doing it in certain kriyas, you're reciting Sanskrit words, satnam, which means the truth is in me. And you're just saying it over and over and over.
做那个双手手指这样摆放的动作。这是一个我记不起名字的手印。然后你保持手臂向上举起。在做某些克里亚练习时，你会背诵梵文词汇“Satnam”，意思是真理在我心中。你只是不断地重复它。
Satnam, satnam, satnam, satnam. I'll just do it for minutes. It's the most empowering thing, because you feel it in your diaphragm. But it's just telling your body these tones resonate with our soul. So you're doing it you're bringing your energy in and penetrating it out into the world and saying like the truth is in me I am the truth I am the truth I am the truth so it's all
Satnam, satnam, satnam, satnam。我会连续做几分钟。这是最令人振奋的事情，因为你能感觉到它在横膈膜的震动。这只是在告诉你的身体，这些音调与我们的灵魂产生共鸣。所以你正在做的是将能量汇聚，并将其穿透到世界中，说“真理在我心中，我是真理，我是真理，我是真理”，所以这一切都是关于……
about like I am I am powerful not not giving away your power not saying I'm I'm just a just a tiny drop of water and blah, blah, blah. It's like, no, I am, I am truth. I am its enemy. And I think that's what swords, when we're talking about clarity and things like that, it's about what is really, really true. Well, my wife has named her Katana. I gave her a Katana for Mother's Day
关于“我是，我是强大的”，而不是放弃你的力量，不是说“我只是，我只是小小的一滴水”之类的。而是说“不，我是，我是真理。我是它的敌人”。我认为这就是剑的含义，当我们谈论清晰度之类的事情时，它是关于什么是真正真实的。嗯，我妻子给她的武士刀取了名字。我在母亲节送了她一把武士刀。
and she knows German. She's of like Czech descendancy and she also is a teacher. So I was holding out for like a name like Adelweiss or teacher's glance or something, but she named it Final Lesson. So that's on our library. She's got a kind of a, it's traditional, but it has a flower kind of rosemaling painting
她懂德语。她有捷克血统，也是一名教师。所以我一直期待着像“雪绒花”或“教师的目光”之类的名字，但她把它命名为“最终一课”。所以它现在放在我们的书房里。它有一种传统的风格，但在刀鞘上有类似玫瑰彩绘的花朵图案。
on the, on the sail. So I don't know, I was hoping you could do it up there, but I didn't have time to set up the computer. Well, that's good. I'm sure you've got stuff to get to. You got anything else you want to sign off on? The psychology of swords. All right.
在刀鞘上。所以我不知道，我本来希望你能在上面展示一下，但我没时间设置电脑。好吧，那很好。我相信你还有别的事要忙。你还有什么想在结束前说的吗？关于剑的心理学。好的。
Yeah. No, this was fun. We will see you guys next week. Thank you so much. Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。不，这很有趣。我们下周再见。非常感谢。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。